I'm on problem number seven.
Josephine's daily exercise
routine consists of swimming,
cycling, and running
in that order.
So swimming, cycling, and
running in that order.
She runs faster than she swims,
and cycles faster than
she runs, like most people.
If she does not rest between the
activities, which of the
following could be the graph
of the distance she covers
during the entire time of
her exercise routine?
So I'm not going to even
look at the choices.
And I'll just give you an
intuition and then you can
look for the choices
that match it.
So if I were to graph distance
versus time, the slope of my
line is going to be
my speed, right?
Because what is speed?
It's distance per time.
And that's the same
thing as slope.
It's rise over run.
So in this context, that would
be the slope of the line.
So what you want is a situation
where she swims
first-- which is her slowest--
then she cycles-- which is her
fastest-- then she runs-- which
is kind of in between.
So what you're going to have
is a low slope, then a very
high slope, and then you want
kind of a medium slope.
So it's going to look
something like this.
Because she swims first, so
that's the slowest exercise,
so maybe it'll be like that.
Then she cycles, which is her
fastest exercise, so maybe it
will look something like that.
And then she runs, which is
kind of an in-between
exercise, so maybe it looks
something like this.
So which of the choices
looks like that?
Where you start relatively
slow, you peak out pretty
fast, and then you do something
that looks a little
bit faster-- that has a higher
slope than this.
And if I look at all
of the choices, it
looks like choice E.
Choice E is actually pretty
close to what I drew.
If you look at the other
choices, choice A she goes
slow, then medium, then fast.
So that's like if she cycled
last, right?
In choice B she does her slow
thing last. That looks like
she's swimming last. Choice C
looks like she's swimming last
as well, because that's the
slowest. And then choice D
looks like she cycles, then
she swims, then she runs.
So it's definitely choice E.
You go slow, fast,
and then medium.
Next problem.
Problem eight.
In the xy-coordinate systems,
square root of 6-- sorry, the
point is square root of 6 comma
k-- is one of the points
of intersection of the graphs.
So these are the graphs.
y is equal to x squared minus
7, and y is equal to minus x
squared plus j.
Fair enough.
Where j is a constant.
What is the value of j?
So we know the x-coordinate
where it intersects, right?
We know it intersects
at square root of 6.
So intersection means that the
y values are the same for a
given x value.
That's what intersects.
So we can set these two
equations equal to each other.
So we could say, x squared--
we could set the y values
equal to each other-- x squared
minus 7 is equal to
this: minus x squared plus j.
Now we could keep things in
terms of x or we could-- well
let's just algebraically play
with this a little bit.
And I hope you understand that
this is what we would do to
solve for the intersection of
these two graphs, if we wanted
to solve for the x value.
And we could play with
this a little bit.
We could add x squared
to both sides.
You get 2x squared minus
7 is equal to j.
And what's x?
We know where these intersect.
We know one of the points
where they intersect is
square root of 6.
So let's input-- let's replace
x with square root of 6.
So 2 times square root of 6
squared minus 7 is equal to j.
What's the square root
of 6 squared?
It's just 6, right?
So it's 2 times 6 minus
7 is equal to j.
So 12 minus 7 is equal to j.
5 is equal to j.
And that is choice A.
Problem nine.
If the absolute value of 2 minus
x is less than 3, which
of the following is a
possible value of x?
So this means that 2 minus
x is less than 3.
Right?
So I guess the way you can
think about is that the
difference between 2 and
x is going to be
less than 3, right?
The other way you could view
it is that the negative of
this-- x minus 2-- is going
to be less than 3.
Right?
We could have also said 2
minus x is greater than
negative 3.
That's the other thing we
could have written.
And what I did is I just-- this
is either going to be a
positive or a negative, right?
So if it's a positive, we just
say 2 minus x is less than 3.
If x is going to be greater than
2, then we could say that
x minus 2 is less than 3.
Because then it would be a
negative number and then it
would become positive.
Hope I didn't confuse you.
So if this is true you would
get-- let's see-- you would
get, if I were to add x to both
sides I'd get 2 is less
than 3 plus x.
Subtract 3 from both sides.
You get negative 1
is less than x.
This one, add 2 to both sides.
You get x is less than 5.
So x is greater than negative
1 and it is less than 5.
So if you look at all of the
choices-- it has to be less
than 5 and greater than negative
1-- so out of all of
those choices, the only choice
that is less than 5 is choice
A, which is 4.
And you could look at it.
You could actually just
try out the numbers.
And frankly, even if you got
confused by absolute value,
you could have just tried
each of the choices.
2 minus 4 is minus 2.
The absolute value of negative
2 is just 2, which
is less than 3.
So that's right.
So you could have actually just
tried out the choices if
this confused you.
And that actually might have
been faster because in the
worst case, you'd have to try
out five choices and each of
them would have taken a few
seconds to evaluate.
But sometimes it's good to
do it mathematically.
But I wouldn't wrong you for--
I wouldn't blame you for just
trying things out as well.
Ten.
OK.
If all interior angles of the
polygon are congruent, then x
is equal to-- OK so this
is interesting.
All of the angles of this
polygon are congruent.
So it's a pentagon.
So it's 1, 2-- like that--
3, 4, and 5.
I didn't draw really
that congruent.
And actually this line keeps
going like this.
And the important thing to
realize with any of these
triangles is, if I were to
draw-- there's a formula for
the angles of a polygon, but I
always-- so the way to think
about it is that these are all
going to be equal angles.
So think of it this way.
These are five equal
triangles.
Let me think of it
the best way.
So they're telling us-- we
want to figure out what x
degrees is, right?
Well this x degrees
is going to be the
same as this x degrees.
And how do I know that?